let's talk dr. Phil he's rescued a lot
of people but jackass star Bam Margera
maybe his toughest test besides his
struggle with sobriety Bam was just
charged with trespassing after an
incident in an LA Hotel and could be
headed to jail his life is literally a
mess right now and that's why he reached
out to dr. Phil for help
it's another et exclusive people have an
image of Bambi in this kind of wild and
crazy guy how much of his old lifestyle
is he still living it's part of who he
is there's an intense confrontation
between Bam and his wife but there's a
good reason the father of almost two
year-old Phoenix personally begged dr.
Phil for help did you get to a point
where you knew you were drinking too
much yeah tell me about your little boy
he's like my best friend I've known him
not even to me
so you'd die for him yeah big time when
the question is will you live for him he
went into detox he checked himself out
to get a dr. Phil tattoo on his neck
come on I got to pay my respects to dr.
felt usually there are six or seven
relapses before somebody finally gets
traction when they're dealing with this
kind of disease and so is this the time
that van will turn it around I don't
know since their first meeting four
weeks ago Bam has been in three
different treatment centers but dr. Phil
is hopeful for the 39 year-old sobriety
so many celebs reach out to you looking
for help
you have no idea if people had any idea
the people that I do that with in
Hollywood they
would be stunned and they will never
know the episode airs Monday meanwhile
big shout out to my man dr. Phil his
3,000 episode airs this month
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]